(audience cheers)
("Wrapped in Red")
♪ Everybody's happy ♪
♪ Snow is falling down ♪
♪ Prayers are being answered ♪
♪ Miracles all around ♪
♪ From afar I've loved you ♪
♪ But never let it show ♪
♪ And every year another ♪
♪ December comes and goes ♪
♪ Always watching ♪
♪ Never reaching ♪
♪ But this Christmas ♪
♪ I'm gonna risk it all ♪
♪ This Christmas ♪
♪ I'm not afraid to fall ♪
♪ So I'm at your door with nothing more ♪
♪ Than words I've never said ♪
♪ In all this white, you'll see me like ♪
♪ You've never seen me yet ♪
♪ Wrapped in red ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ I'll never feel you ♪
♪ If I don't tell you ♪
♪ This Christmas ♪
♪ I'm gonna risk it all ♪
♪ I'm not afraid to fall ♪
♪ So I'm at your door with nothing more ♪
♪ Than words I've never said ♪
♪ In all this white, you'll see me like ♪
♪ You've never seen me yet ♪
♪ Wrapped in red ♪
(audience cheers)
(indistinct)
(Kelly claps)